all right let's go what's up everybody
its Bazzi Here I am currently
quarantined at my apartment in Los
Angeles California hopefully you guys
are all doing the same somewhere safe
but nonetheless I am here today to do a
special edition of ten things I can't
live without first up is as it created
being cramped up all day and not being
able to go outside this offers released
for me to creatively express myself
offices I'm able to create music and
[Music]
Gibson hummingbird this guitar is really
special to me
she's amazing I've written a lot of
beautiful music on it I've taken it to
Asia Europe and Hawaii and I use it on a
lot of my last album this is like my
tour bus guitar nice just being able to
have instruments around all the time I
think you know makes me feel a little
less crazy in here that I could jump on
the piano or jump over the top and just
get something out if I need to
[Music]
thank you
I grew up on this this is pretty much my
job in a box
what's it so right off the bat these are
just about everything you're going to
need to enjoy yourself for the next few
months of course we got classic super
smash bros mario 25 mario party 5 is an
unbelievably entertaining game it's
probably occupied next on my list be
classic classic classic like this if you
look at all my central so far you
probably think I'm I'm a five-year-old
boy which is pretty accurate to the
spirit that lives inside of you but when
I was a kid I actually always tried to
build Legos and intersected crazy zany
it gets enough like five minutes and
stacking them up in a stupid random
manner as an adult saying that I'm
doobies it's so peaceful to just
redirection to me you know do something
that's almost purposeless has no reward
or anything just good for the money I
think you just focus on something
accomplished itself
you got the staff but Legos for the
quarantine
and one of my best friends and
definitely important essentially McRib
is growing up the furniture that we had
the furniture that we used was never
like a choice or selection you know
basically got the hand-me-downs of
furniture for family and friends and it
was just something you had it was never
something I was specific and tailored to
your okay so this was the first piece of
furniture I've bought every time I sit
on an X on the list of essentials art
supplies as simple as that I think this
is important I think if you plan to be
an artist or whatever it is if you're
not I think this is healthy for
everybody the Blake acrylic colors
design books this one's actually really
cool art of architecture in their
campuses in here I can actually give you
an example of what I mean by the saying
that you don't have to buy a very
impatient guy especially with art I like
things to be immediate I like that's why
I like music because you can create it
so quickly I get stuff with my brain in
them I'm good eager to get it out so
this is my
are you really strange personal stuff
like under this I wrote a hole just on
brain flow on to this next we have a
very important element and I hate to say
is one I've been indulging in a lot
during party
it's the spirit session a lot of mine
this is actually my favorite bottle of
wine this is an Opus one delicious I
like anything like that
people pay specific attention to the
details which is these wines are so many
things is so much specificness to it the
creation of itself will be done with
these in like the next three days next
so my fridge is pretty green you would
think I was a super healthy guy who saw
this but I look at to vegans my
girlfriend and her twin sister so I'm
like than 80% vegan I definitely try and
like I may not lifestyle for many
reasons but get the beyond burgers we've
got some classic dessert options this is
what I said I was 80% begin this is
probably when the other 20% comes in is
with these Snickers ice cream bars are
unbelievable these are a gift from the
heavens these are magical that
the across the bowls of course have the
accessible scribbles if you know you
know this right here is my wife 80 grand
piano I love this into place I mean when
you walk in it's right there in your
face I like the idea of friends being
over and any time they jump on the piano
I spend a lot of time on it and this
right here this is super essential it's
very important he's actually probably
like the main reason why I moved in this
place just feel so open a lot of the
views in LA are filled with building a
new traffic it's long this one's just so
green nice having a place to kind of
come out you know things feel so big in
your world things
okay everybody that's a wrap
I want to thank GQ for having me times
you really tough right now I hope
everybody's safe
[Music]